When contemplating the meaning of life, it
is easy to become confused and disheartened
as we find that there is no conclusive overarching
meaning that we can hold on to.
When it comes to trying to find some grand
purpose that humanity is serving to, we can
only really answer questions with more questions.
And every question we ask seems to only widen
the scope of our perspective of the universe
and consequently reduce the significance of
our existence.
For every step we take away from our self
in order to get a better view of what’s
around us, we become smaller and smaller.
So what do we do?
How can we find meaning and purpose in our
life if we can’t understand or define our
purpose outside of it?
In the scope of the boundless and perpetual
universe, our individual lives are fundamentally
meaningless.
But that does not imply that they can’t
still be filled with meaning.
As humans, through the power of imagination
and higher consciousness, we have the incredible
ability to create meaning within the meaningless.
We are creators, able to imagine meaning and
attach it to the things around us.
We can create and carry out concepts like
love, morality, and success.
We can create narratives out of our lives
and experience wonder and inspiration.
We are all like children playing games of
imagination with the world.
And it is through this concept that we can
uncover life’s meaning.
The meaning of human life is simply to create
meaning.
To play and enjoy the game of imagination
as best we can.
To accept that we do not understand our overarching
purpose and that we may not even have on.
And instead, work to connect with and enjoy
the life we can create around us.
The relationships and friendships that we
form.
The passions that we follow.
The values and outlooks that we behold.
These types of things are the true meaning
of human life.
We should appreciate our life, not because
there is some grand purpose or meaning behind
it, but because there is endless meaning that
we can create and enjoy within it.